كلا الطرفين لاسيما كلجدار اوغلو و رجب
طيب اردوغان يعولان على فئه الشباب في هذه
الانتخابات كيف يقارب كل فريق مخاطبه هذه
الفئه
نعم جلال هذه الانتخابات التي صمتت
اصواتها الصاخبه قبل خمس ساعات من الان
محوريه جدا ولعل اهم فئه حرجه ستتعاطى مع
هذه الانتخابات ويحرص كلا الطرفين على خطب
ودها هي فئه الشباب
وهناك فئه حوالي خمس ملايين سيصوتون للمره
الاولى هم يعني بلغوا ثمانيه عشر عاما في
هذه الانتخابات هذه الفئه التي تبلغ حوالي
خمس ملايين وتمثل ثمانيه بالمئه من مجموع
الناخبين هذه الكتله الحرجه هي هي التي
يتنافس عليها الفريقان خلال ايام الماضيه
جلال تحدثوا مع هذه الفئه قابلتهم تحدث
اليهم عن طموحاتهم لاحظت ان ذمه انقساما
حادا تشده هذه الفئه بدورها كما تشده بقيه
تركيا لكن اهم شيء كان في اذهانهم من خلال
احاديث معهم هو موضوع الاقتصاد يبدو فعلا
ان الاشكاليه الاقتصاديه من اهم العوامل
التي ستحدد من سيحكم تركيا خلال فتره
القادمه
ايضا من هذه الفئه ان التواصل الاجتماعي
التعاطي مع التواصل الاجتماعي ما ينشروا
في الانترنت يؤثر في هذه الفئه جدا ومعظم
معلوماتها من خلال ما فهمته من احاديث
معها ياتي عن طريق شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي وهذا تحدي لاحظه كلا المرشحان
الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان وزعيم
المعارضه
كلاهما حرص من خلال حملته طيله الاسبوعين
الماضيين على ظهور عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ومحاوله مخاطبه هذه الفئه هذه
الفئه الشبابيه جلال تتميز بامر لافت ايضا
وهو انها لم تعايش تركيا القديمه انما
ولدت في ظل حزب العداله والتنميه وبالتالي
هي لا تعرف حزبا اخر وبالتالي ربما يرى
ابناء العداله والحريه انها ينقصها الوعي
حسب رايهم فيما يتعلق بطبيعه حكم حزب
العداله والتنميه لانهم لم يروا تركيا قبل
نهضتها الاقتصاديه خلال العشرين عاما للم
اضيه وبالتالي هذه الفئه بدورها بما انها
محوريه هي ايضا منقسمه يمكنك ان ترى
ورائها اولئك الشباب الاتراك كغيرهم من
خلال احاديثنا معهم مشغولون
ومقسمون بين اتجاهين وحده وغدا ان شاء
الله يوم الاحد هو الذي سيحدد طبيعته هذه
الفئه وموقفها ولمن ستصوت وهي كما اسلفنا
تبلغ حوالي ثمانيه بالمئه من مجموع
الاصوات وكلى الطرفين حريص على ان يخاطبها
جلال